[Music]
also blue we need a there's a there's a
cake truck Masons
[Applause]
it's good it's 300 pounds whoever saw
this cake before gotta live it's a very
good people who don't want eat chocolate
should not eat this cake oh say about
3,500
that's a seven foot pounds of that means
well feed the whole Tour de France for a
day what film arson is or describe Phil
Morrison you might have written to say
Phil Morrison
okay Phil is the kind of person that you
only meet once in a lifetime and Phil's
the one for me when I was a student I
met Phil at a time when he represented
the very spirit of excitement that has
inspired a whole generation of students
he's the kind of person but the minute
he walked on a stage everyone would say
my god
science is exciting and he conveyed that
enthusiasm with without any particular
content just as something exciting to
learn and for me the major thing about
Phil has been the sheer enthusiasm for
life but I what I like to call when I
talk about Phil and they say what how do
you describe Phil in one phrase I say
phil has a joie de physique other people
other joie de vivre but Phil is Ron de
physique he he makes you want to love
physics and physics I think the film
means just the understanding of the
natural world how we how a human being
thinks about natural phenomena and that
Jawad of the sea comes along every time
he ever says anything about science so
if I have one phrase about Bill
miss Rwanda disease
or so just if I asked you to describe
Philip or what he meant to you or an
incident in your life or sort sink bite
that we might use at some point in the
celebration phil has been such a joy in
science and life and when one felt that
one could go to him when one was talking
about things which were not connected
only the physics not only with science
but with lots of other things together
many years ago I I sent it online SOS we
want to make programs for science for
children in schools in India where where
there are no laboratories there is no
facilities and we have made a brief that
science is everywhere that method of
science is more important and that
understanding science and trying to get
can burn more important and the content
that's on them and I said will you stop
everything in between please send me
some briefs and sure enough we can three
means I got no letter saying there are
hundred graves yes we applaud your
decision that the method of science is
more important and that that science is
everywhere and to science monk and man
liberating and since that day we have
had a continuing relationship besides
physics in human applications of science
including disarmament communication
education
[Music]
my
sorry well thank you people that were
you going Wow well now you were very
good friends there his name is Mike
Savage oh I know Mike right well those
intersecting were alright yes it
certainly is
okay of course I realize you have to
[Music]
well I've been inspired by Phil ever
since I've been a physics student and
undergraduate because not only for the
physics that Phil has but for his all
the other things that he's interested in
he was always my idol in the sense
someone who has curiosity about the
world in general not only how to
calculate it but the items of the world
the tools of the world I've always loved
that curiosity of him so he's been a
foundation for me especially moving from
physics into teaching non-scientists
which is not an easy thing to do when
you come from a background graduate
school going on in becoming a
professional so to me phil is
quintessential cross-cultural person
well I've known Phil since the days it
was almost later at MIT
came to work with us in cosmic rays
that was when we really had a fairly
close collaboration man sir could you
talk to me and borough Rossi screw
it's been a very close collaboration as
to physics ever since then phil has
always been a source of ideas and an
inspiration to it wonderful colleague to
work with
okay well I became a friend of
Fillmore's much later in 1967 I was
invited to come to MIT from presidents
and then I met him in Trieste there was
a conference from the whole of physics
and I was fascinated this bag plus I've
met Bruno Rossi and plates this group
convinced me to come at MIT
then I became also a neighbor we are
they an office together with Phil and
with the passing open door he's a
marvelous person as a friend and as a
neighbor and I can tell you I will say
go to in Soviet Union he has many
friends they are too it not only is an
exercise which is really internationally
minded is a citizen of the world and
what we'll miss it greatly I don't think
he's replaceable openness
open-mindedness well he has an
incredible knowledge of physics and he
can apply it he can apply it over a much
broader range that can most of us and so
if you have a problem Phil always brings
a perspective to that problem which you
probably haven't thought of yourself
he's just a wonderful guy to have around
bounce ideas off 99% of the time he'll
tell you why you were wrong
oh there are many but let me add a
little bit to what I you know what
strikes me or feel is that is freedom in
other words you know in size you are
tied to formulas and so on especially if
you do theory you tend to get quite
constrained and they burst through that
and it really especially if you are
younger than you know it lets you free
and that is this liberating influence
that nobody almost as in the press or
Marcin wants many years ago and the
Department of Jacob Bronowski when
Bronowski was here as a different
professor so he doesn't remember the
instant I know present Morrison largely
as a member of an audience and the
experience have been as listener to him
to my sense is that of being exposed to
a tremendous source of energy that in
essence helps me in my own world which
is quite different than his different
fields and so forth what did you feel a
civil engineering and can you think of
any names specific incident you don't
known that well so that I do not I do
not know an
let's recall there are so many the in
fact I start with most again is that
liberating influence the other one is
that accept you immediately as a frame
even if there is a difference of age or
whatever or opinion or opinions there
are so many of them in fact isn't the
difference of opinion and skepticism
part of his body yes yes the ability to
be different thank you
well he's such a polymath it's hard to
find anything he doesn't know about and
of course one delights in those moments
when you can in fact trip him up and
find that you know something he doesn't
because it's so rare now I'm always
amazed at how versatile phil is he
really does just seem to know everything
and I just can't believe that he reads
all the books that he obviously does
there any incidents that you can think
of any of those anecdotes or if you had
to say give me a 30-second anecdote that
expresses fill in some way part of his
personality I'd have to stop and think
about that a little bit maybe maybe I
can in a in a moment work what kinds of
inspiration or help or assistance I've
always enjoyed enormous ly arguing with
him about Kepler and Galileo and I
talked about Kepler and Galileo
yesterday and and after it was over he
allowed that I still hadn't got the
point
that's because I'm a kepler enthusiast
and he's very much like Galileo he is
the physicist who's poaching on
astronomy in a very creative way both of
them did it
he's well what is rather astonishing to
me is that in addition to reading all of
the stuff about current physics he also
reads the journal for the history of
astronomy and any number of other things
relating to the background the
historical background so he's very
knowledgeable about all kinds of crazy
details about Galileo and how Galileo
was in the one good place for getting
glass so that he could make his own
lenses and things of this sort I've
learned a lot of historical things from
him actually
and maybe Howie's a human being or Anna
scientists and historian and a poly man
whatever
well Phil really has been a lot of
encouragement to me since I've come to
MIT actually a number of the people
who've been working in cosmology for
years have been rather slow to accept
the inflationary universe I think people
do tend to become ingrained with
different ideas and fills nothing like
that at all he's been very enthusiastic
towards the work that I've been doing
and has been a tremendous amount of
encouragement and also a certain amount
of guidance
he's always urged me to try to emphasize
the features of the inflationary
universe that do not depend on the
details of particle theory and I think
he's right about that the details of the
particle theory that are involved here
are not very well established and I
think it's very important to separate
those aspects of inflation which do not
depend on the details of the particle
theory from those that do limps of a
conversation or insider discussion
I find I can't really think of a
specific conversation like you're
looking for sorry in 10 20 words or less
give me a thumb nail sketch of Phil
Morrison starting with Phil Morrison I
he's always very interested in young
people and it was in the context of
teaching and working on curriculum
reform that I first met both Phil and
Phyllis I remember one fourth of July
when he came over to our house and one
of my children had mixed up a lot of
fireworks which he set off in our
backyard and Phil then got into a very
philosophical sort of reminiscing vein
and he said you know I remember when I
was back in Los Alamos and I was in
charge of calibrating the instruments
and in order to do this we had to set
off 20 tons of TNT and they brought this
stuff in on the truck and he said they
were just heaving these boxes out like
this he said I was really terrified and
the man in charge said oh this stuff is
perfectly safe here I'll show you and he
set it up in a huge wall of the cartons
of the boxes of TNT and had somebody get
a machine gun out and machine-gun it he
said Phil said I didn't stay to watch
20 words what would you say would you
sum up the call well he's like Phil is
knows so much and yet is in many ways so
humble about it and he will take the
time to come and talk with you or to
answer questions or to help discuss some
odd point and you never feel that he's
too busy to do it and yet you know with
all his responsibilities that he's
terribly busy person is enthusiasm for
knowledge the way in which he reads
practically everything in sight and
soaks it in and really puts across the
enthusiasm for learning new things
better than anybody else I know
to the pasta
well I've never worked with him as a
colleague I just happen to know him
because I've been at MIT here for a few
years and my first real contact with him
in his work I think was when I saw the
exhibit at Expo in Montreal
you know the 67 I guess it was and they
have building IBM had put up and one of
the films that had been done in this
sort of three-dimensional type of
illness by I guess was Charles Eames
really exhibited the the book he'd
written you know powers of ten kind of
good where you you go out into space you
know we're sort of a different order of
magnitude from your solar system to your
galaxy on beyond and then you go down to
sort of a micro micro infinity is just
very impressed by both that presentation
and also the book itself which is a kind
of a classic you can still buy it or
hundun I hoop here it's a it's a real
classic
the sense of infinity and dimension and
of course once you come in contact with
with him you know he's exceptional
because I I myself was originally
trained in science although I I do other
things but the he still has the old
spark of what science was about when it
was in its formative idealistic sort of
phase it was a it was a thing that
people you know found is a tremendously
creative type of force and he still
conveys that together with the unusual
sort of human quality which I think gets
lost over the period that I'm talking
about
you know which goes back you know
several decades and when you come into
contact with him you know that he's an
exceptional human being of course an
element that needs to be constantly
added to science as more and more is
accomplished with it and the purpose of
it becomes more and more a matter of
doubt and concern
yeah well of course everybody is notice
this this is not a new observation but I
think it's it's a fact that people who
create things although in a way they're
accused of this it's a compliment it's
that they're childish you know it's a
very childlike quality it's the question
of why is the grass green why is the sky
blue they've never answered either of
those questions adequately but if you
ask a person that they laugh at you
because it seems like it's so simplistic
that you don't really need to bother
about it but when you think about it if
we knew how the grass worked we'd be
pretty well off we wouldn't have to make
food the way we do and it's that kind of
thing you know it's just a very
ingenuous way of looking at the world
and asking a lot of questions and the
other aspect is always having a sense of
humor
and it shows - is very refreshing you
know to have a sense of humor about
everything and also to be totally honest
and curious about not only what you know
but what you don't know I mean you know
right away that if he doesn't know
something he'll tell you most people try
to hide what they don't know and I think
that's a very very human and a very very
wonderful quality for creativity
very short state where the quality of
skepticism well I think in the in the
period there where the the the student
was giving him you know this gift and
and making a little statement about him
I think he summed that up that he he
referred to that fact that he was always
open always had this sense of humor very
much a model of how you ought to be if
you wanted to be a searcher a creator a
person who you know was in a sense not
hiding his ignorance but always willing
to find out the answer by admitting what
he didn't know and I think in a sense
what he's done is he's conveyed the
essential posture for a person to have
to be really creative and really to be a
searcher for the facts as well as you
can find them with the equipment you
know that we've been given
we had a lot of conversation going on
around this table there are I thought
you were doing the helicopter I knew
that you was the conversation I love
Bill Maher's and when I think of Phil I
think of Phyllis whom I love just as
much
I really cannot think of one without the
other
he's the simplest complicated man I know
and she's the most complicated simple
woman I know I have
never heard him without balance without
consideration without intelligence and
as far as I'm concerned he knows all
about everything great pleasure is to
have dinner at his house because on one
side of the table is a microscope and
the other side is a computer and I think
after this birthday there'll be a
transmitter and a receiver and if a
person has done interesting worker if
there's a bread fill you want you want
to know what we feel about Phil I'll
speak for myself and I'm sure they'll
all agree with me
Phil Marcin is a man with incredible
eyes all eyes would speak of a kind of
enthusiasm which is so extraordinary
that just to be around the man is an
exciting experience we're not quite
putting your finger on it you know he
prompts you to think perhaps in ways you
haven't thought before and the eyes I
want do it you know what I mean I was
extraordinary
absolutely there's a lot of time I can't
hear what are you saying so I'm a little
bad but I'm coming away so excited from
him
even when he's just asking question
deferred yesterday but you know it's a
tempo of his voice and he speaks fast
like all those scientists they speak it
yeah you know Phyllis Phyllis is an
artist and that's that's our connection
but to be around the man and to listen
to him talk about his enthusiasms
there's a real connection that because
science and art do have some connection
vague perhaps or very close it's hard to
say but when you're talking to me you
think you're talking to an artist and in
a curious way I think film was married
before wasn't think I know that and
Phyllis was to people that are so one is
very rarely in one's lifetime in the
presence of a great love and that exists
between Phil and Phyllis Morrison and
it's awesome and beautiful and entire
and various
[Music]
for any technical reason I should not
take tapes one and through eleven with
me with me tape twelve is in there Sam
will give it to me later
right
[Music]
I hope you don't lose the whole thing
someday not too much left yes okay
when we was in Wisconsin lemons of
summer school in Wisconsin
[Music]
I don't want to and no no okay that's
fine college eyes but other that's
explaining why why I'm right everybody
and if this is the last ten minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
see what do I have for wine nurse here
where's that winder okay I have to wine
nurse do the 100 if you can get the 125
pound test which is the small diameter
line smaller yeah just do that don't
worry with the fat line I think I have
all the fat line here yeah and you could
start it either in whichever and fine
seems easier for you
i'm IM letting it out what I'm doing is
pumping it that gives it alpha to then
bringing my arm forward every pump I'm
actually letting it out three feet every
time I do that
[Music]
[Applause]